Speaker 1: So Joe Biden is ending negotiations
with Republicans over the infrastructure bill
and this now puts the possibility of budget
reconciliation in focus.
Joe Biden got off to a relatively fast start
immediately signing a bunch of executive orders,
undoing some of the nonsense that Donald Trump
did, getting the one point nine trillion dollar
covid stimulus passed not as quickly as we
would have liked, but still by Washington
terms relatively quickly and then rolling
out a very successful vaccination program.
But what is next?
And we've been talking about, well, if it's
not going to be infrastructure, it's got to
be something else that's big.
But infrastructure really seems like the way
to go.
Joe Biden has been negotiating with Senator
Shelley Moore Capito and some other Republicans
over infrastructure legislation.
And CBS News now reports that it's over.
Joe Biden has said to Senator Cappato that
the last Republican proposal doesn't meet
the essential needs of our country to fix
roads and bridges.
It doesn't prepare the country for a future
that will be reliant on clean energy and it
doesn't create jobs.
And this is according to the White House press
secretary.
And so what is now next?
And the answer is, I don't know.
When you look at the details that have been
released of this negotiation that Joe Biden
had with with House and Senate lawmakers,
the he reduced his plan by over a trillion
dollars.
That's a big concession from Joe Biden already.
And then Republicans came up in new investments
by only one hundred and fifty billion.
And this is the prototypical situation where
you negotiate and you negotiate and negotiate
with Republicans.
You settle on something in the middle and
then they don't vote for it anyway.
So what was all of the negotiation for now?
I am not against Joe Biden doing some discussion.
I think it's fine that he did that because
now he can say we gave major concessions,
we sliced a trillion dollars off of this thing,
and then they wanted to give us essentially
nothing.
And so we're moving on without them.
I don't think that that's a waste of time.
What will become a waste of time is now if
they don't simply make this happen via budget
reconciliation, can they actually do that?
I don't know.
I don't know that Joe Manchin actually wants
the bill the way that it is.
And by the way, I mean, from an infrastructure
perspective, West Virginia is a disaster.
And by infrastructure, I mean traditional
infrastructure like bridges and tunnels and
roads in this type of thing.
But broadband infrastructure, health care,
infrastructure, educational infrastructure
and on and on.
If there is anybody in the Senate who should
be desperate for the biggest possible infrastructure
package, it actually should be Joe Manchin.
But as we talked about yesterday, I wasn't
kidding when I said Joe Manchin was going
to be a problem.
And it's not even clear to me that Democrats
have the 50 votes in order to pass this via
budget reconciliation.
If we step back for a second.
I've gotten emails from people saying, is
this something that can be done via budget
reconciliation?
Sometimes you'll hear some on the left say
Joe Biden should just do Medicare for all
through budget reconciliation.
First of all, Joe Biden doesn't support Medicare
for all.
But putting that aside, my best reading of
when budget reconciliation can be used would
not allow it to be used for Medicare.
For all that being said, there is no question
that budget reconciliation can be used to
pass Joe Biden's infrastructure bill with
50 votes in the Senate rather than the 60
you would normally need.
But that's only if you have all 50 votes from
Democratic senators.
And it's not at this point clear that Joe
Biden actually does.
The New York Times also reporting on the stalled
negotiations not really stalled, ended negotiations,
saying after weeks of failed efforts to bridge
deep divides, the president pulled the plug,
turning to a bipartisan group to try to salvage
a chance at compromise.
My question is, how long do you keep going
at it from this approach?
Because you end up with what are sometimes
these Pyrrhic victories where you do so much
damage in the process of negotiating something
that Republicans will accept that you are
really compromising on your ability to pass
something that substantive.
And with the current Republicans, as we saw
with the covid bill, sometimes you spend all
this time negotiating and they all vote against.
It anyway, so my sense is that we're sort
of getting to the end here.
The New York Times writes sort of pseudo optimistically,
the breakdown did not close off the possibility
of a bipartisan compromise entirely.
And the White House signaled that the president
would continue seeking one.
He shifted his focus to a bipartisan group
of senators, senators who have been working
separately on an alternative, calling three
of them personally to cheer on efforts and
encourage them to work with top White House
officials to hammer out a deal.
But even if the group can agree on a plan
palatable to Joe Biden, there's no guarantee
enough Republicans would accept it.
That that is exactly the point that needs
to be considered.
How much longer are we doing this with Republicans
who, you know, it's conceivable that you get,
I don't know, Joe Manchin and Mitt Romney
in a room and they come up with something
that they say they would support.
But then do you still have 60 votes or are
you put in the position of having to go through
budget reconciliation and then you're just
arguing with your own side?
You're arguing with Joe Manchin.
Joe, listen, we have forty nine.
We need 50.
What are you willing to do for us?
And this is the exact I mean, when you talk
about the type of partizan gridlock that sometimes
it's bipartisan gridlock, when you talk about
the type of partizan gridlock where the American
people just look at it and say, this is why
I am I am disillusioned about even voting.
This is why we have voter turnout of 50, 55
percent at midterms, because on the one hand,
we understand that every two years we get
to say we don't like the people representing
us in the House of Representatives every four
years.
You get to say that about the White House.
Every six years you get to say that about
your senator from your particular state.
But then when you see this stuff where Democrats
aren't even all on the same page, the things
that Republicans and Democrats agree upon,
they don't have support for from the broader
party, or you end up in a situation where
even those with the majority, in this case
Democrats, a slim majority, 50 50 with the
tie breaking vote, are negotiating against
themselves.
And will Joe Manchin vote for it?
Will Sinema vote for it?
I get being disillusioned with the system.
And this is sort of like the worst of the
worst of the worst of American politics.
I don't know whether this thing's going to
pass.
If you said, you know, take a bet, I think
55, 45 something passes, how much it will
look like Joe Biden's initial proposal.
I have absolutely no idea.
But I'm interested in hearing from you.
Do you think this will go anywhere?